hallo mein name ist luca letztlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ihr seht ihr schon im titel
eingeblendet wie mache ich meine haare
und zwar genau das ist das was was in
dem was in dem kann kann ich mache eben
nicht immer spaß dass ich genau hat sich
in den heutigen zeiten möchte ich mache
dieses video auf grund vieler faktoren
und zwar erstens habe ich eine komplette
folgen gräser allergie und bin die
ganzen nase putzen und bin total ko
deswegen bin ich jetzt nicht dafür in
der lage sondern richtig krasses video
rausschauen mitschnitt et cetera pp
außerdem ist das so eine der haupt
sachen die mich immer gefragt werden
wenn ich sage ihr solltet ihr fragen
stellen und das ist jetzt endlich mal
dann kann ich sagen okay eine video kann
wie ich ich muss reden lernen ich dumm
da können wir einfach allen leuten die
frage hast du deine haare einfach sagen
hey einer von krieg oder macht also
gehen nach draußen gehen
ich hab keine ahnung ich bin auf jeden
fall total fertig mit der welt ich bin
täglich 30 grad draußen und es ist
anfang juni ich bin ein mensch der
sommer viel viel lieber hat als winter
aber 30 grad und es fühlt sich an wie
790 gramm kürzesten und alles mögliche
deswegen heute nur als kleines video wie
ich mir meine haare machen versteht es
nicht falsch das soll einerseits keine
parodie sein von welchen anderen
youtuber andererseits werde ich mich
auch nicht zu irgendeinem beauty palast
hier auf youtube entwickeln und euch
dann quasi nach und nach immer mehr
stylingprodukte oder so zeigen also das
soll einfach nur jetzt mal sein weil
diese frage unglaublich oft kam und
damit ich das thema endlich auch mal
abgehakt habe außerdem das muss man ja
mittlerweile immer dazu sagen
kein produkt was ich irgendwie ich hier
irgendwie gleich benutzen werde oder ihr
irgendwie sehe werde ich vom bezahlt ist
es alles eigentlich runs produkte ich
meinen irgendwelche tollen anderen
produkte tier feiern oder so das soll
nur so zeigen wie ich es mache aber ich
bekomme überhaupt kein geld für
irgendwas hier mit video gibt meiner
mama
ich kann so gar nicht tanzen fällt mir
auf den ball zunächst einmal packe ich
hole meine hände halte ich das schaffe
und meinen lassen haben luca die haare
sollen nach sein also du musst die
vorher mit wasser voll machen wenn
partikeln späte so verriet nun also
endlich das shampoo einen nassen haaren
ich benutze da wirklich irgendeinen
scheiß shampoo also wenn ich irgendwie
mal unterwegs bin in berlin münchen
carado wo auch immer nutze ich
eigentlich immer gegen die seife die im
hotel rumsteht oder irgendein hotel
shampoo oder so wie sie jetzt hier
gerade im hintergrund halte sich wieder
bei meiner familie zu hause bin deswegen
nutze ich eigentlich mal das an meiner
schwester wenn ich irgendwo anders bin
kaufe ich mir eigentlich im supermarkt
wie man oder shampoo was gerade im
angebot des letztens habe ich mir aus
versehen eine spülung gekauft das war
dann nicht so toll was macht eigentlich
eine spülung meine nase kribbelt ich
will dann schwitze ich bin total platz
in der fresse meine nase ist rot meine
augen tränen
aber wisst ihr woher das kommt leicht
ist bei snap chat gesehen und zwar weil
ich gestern abend auf seinem spielplatz
und hab da so ein amerikanisches video
nachgestellt wo leute den ball irgendwo
hin werden und dem nächsten platz liegt
einen vorteil falls sie nicht wisst was
ich meine ich werde euch mal hierhin
auch schon dass man das nature stories
und ich hab halt ich übelste allergie
auf gräser und ja ich glaube nur auf
gräser aber auf jeden fall war sehr
starker gräser fluggästen wollte
unbedingt ins netz story mal unbedingt
machen weil ich das schon so lange plan
unter superkräfte deswegen haben wir das
dann einfach gestern machten und setzt
seitdem bin ich nur am liebsten um eine
stimme deswegen halt wirklich nur dieses
kleine video heute freunde und folgte
bei slapshot das komplett anzuschauen
alte ich bin so fertig wenn ich das auf
jeden fall der shampoo wieder
herausgewaschen habe und mir die haare
irgendwie meppen handtuch abgetrocknet
habe für nicht mit an die haare halt
dementsprechend so ein bisschen ist sie
trocken sind
2000 jahre später nannten sie meine
haare dann immer so aus also die halten
zwar ein bisschen und bleiben oben aber
wenn ich dann irgendwie runter drücken
dann bleibe ich halt auch unten und so
also da ist kein richtiger halt drin
deswegen nehme ich da eigentlich schon
seit jahren immer got to be strandmatten
übrigens ist es kein placement ich sage
euch das nur weil es leute interessiert
der bücher meine haare machte aber ich
bekomme dafür kein geld das so zeigen es
ist halt ich feiere das produkt dich mal
so krass bildschirmen die zuvor mit den
anderen wachsen kauf von den gibt's halt
überall deswegen nehme ich dann
irgendwie mal so ein bisschen also
wirklich nicht viel
eine kleine schicht am finger überall
weltkindertag showcase natürlich gar
nicht sind aber es ist auch echt auch
wenig und dann wünsche ich mir einfach
irgendwie durch die haare
irgendwie wenn man irgendwie alles darin
verteilt ist ist es dann so dass die ja
eigentlich in alle richtungen sascha
wald irgendwie relativ dicke habe ich
mir sagen lassen und ein bisschen zu
viel volumen drin deswegen sind diese
ein bisschen schwer zu händeln also wenn
ich darin nicht mitmache dann stein
stehen dann ist ist ein reines aus stahl
deswegen mache ich die dann eben immer
so dass sie dann so ein bisschen
irgendwie so sind so ein bisschen nach
vorne zeigen ein bisschen zur seite
keine ahnung wieso in die richtung und
damit das ganze auch so ein bisschen
hält nämlich irgendeinen scheiß
haarspray von meiner schwester deswegen
ich habe mir dass er einfach gekauft
weil meine schwester das hatte und ich
weiss ich glaube man kann auch jedes
andere übernehmen also nehmt ihnen ein
scheiß produkt ich meine es ist komplett
legal glaub ich hab keine ahnung ich bin
ja nicht lukas beauty playlist
ansprüchen wir das einfach irgendwohin
damit dass irgend ein bisschen hält und
so sieht das ganze dann auf jeden fall
irgendwie auf meinem kopf und das ist
quasi das komplette geheimnis wie ich
mir meine haare mache also ich wasche
die eigentlich mit einem shampoo dann
trockne ich mir irgendwie trocken mit
langer handtuch erst und dann halt
führen so wie es glaube ich jeder mensch
auf dieser welt machen dann benutze ich
halt irgendeinen wachs und würfel
durcheinander mit
es bringt das ganze dann in richtung mit
haarspray das mache ich erst seit kurzem
weil ich das letzte seiner freundin erst
heraus gefallen habe das haarspray echt
gut funktioniert aber das ist quasi nur
wichtig weil meine haare sind relativ
lang und die fliegen wenn ich irgendwie
durch den wind locker so fliegen die
bälle richtung deswegen hält
heartbreakers ganzheitlichen die einfach
nur ein bisschen zusammen ist aber auch
nicht erst es ja wirklich so wichtig
aber das war es auf jeden fall wie ich
meine haare machen sollten die
eigentlich so sein dass ihr inhalt
durchgehen können dass die nicht
verkleben und gehe ich fühle mich sowie
beauty kann ich muss auf felder mit
ich hoffe euch hat das video gegen die
gefallen jetzt das getan hat freue ich
mich immer nur bewertungen es tut mir
leid dass ich darüber jetzt ein
komplettes video gemacht hab eigentlich
wollte ich das in den nächsten frage
antwort video integrieren nur mit je
zwei grad ich so scheiße und ich glaube
das sieht man und hört man auch dass ich
gerade wirklich nicht dazu in der lage
wenn irgendwas anderes hoch zu lassen
der grund warum nicht thema
und jetzt noch war dann alle die jetzt
gerade sogar noch dran sind
schaut mal dass jedes angekommen das
kissen das ist so blaustich alter ich
könnte heulen sf lotte mit mit luca logo
sogar ihr vorne dran das kissen kommt
bald in den shop ich habe noch kein
genaues datum dafür allerdings wird es
zusammen mit diesen beiden t shirts in
den shop kommen ich weiß irgendwie mal
wenn ich hier zu hause bin mache ich
zeige ich diese t-shirts weil ich habe
auf meinem schreibtisch rumliegen und
ich noch nicht ausgepackt und checkt auf
jeden fall ab und an mal dem
check den auf jeden fall ab und an mal
aus und wenn die sachen launchen im shop
werde ich dazu auch wieder irgendwie
1000 unterschriebenes ticker dabei
packen und so weiter und so fort sondern
war komplett andere themen mit denen uns
heute gar nicht beschäftigen wollen das
war quasi einfach nur wie ich mit meiner
haare machen und ich weiß nicht wie oft
ich jetzt schon im heißen brei geredet
habe es ist jetzt auf jeden fall vorbei
das video
ich lasse ich jetzt einfach nur ruhig
muss auch unbedingt gibt irgendwie mal
schlafen nicht fertig